so you're in the movie hate crime which
you play opposite Jordan saloon yeah
right and I know your dad's also in the
film we talked to Jordan via a podcast
interview last week so he's based in the
south and he was telling us that part of
his business strategy is an actor is to
just really stay in the south and work
on productions that are happening there
and he felt that he was great as a
regional actor I'm wondering about your
strategy I know you're in New York and I
know there's plenty of opportunity there
do you think there are enough acting
jobs to go around in in I know with
Louisiana I think your dad studios are
there Atlanta there's also South
Carolina do you think that that's a good
strategy for people oh yeah I mean you
know everyone's different and I think if
you're from those areas you can be close
to home and so get work and pad your
resume so i think for certain people
it's a great strategy and there's a lot
of good stuff down there and you'll meet
a lot of interesting people so I think
that's that is a good strategy i just
think i like New Yorkers I like the city
and I like the challenge of it and I
know a lot of people there which is nice
but to have a good teacher too but I
think yeah it's great you know if you
want to be in those regional parts of
America I think you'll also see a part
of if you want who the LA eventually i
think it's it's good to be in those
parts of America because you'll if
you're from LA maybe you'll just see a
side of America that you won't
necessarily see in Los Angeles more
normal people more gritty people more
working class and all that jazz right so
it sounds like it's not so much the
place anymore it's just what do you want
to do and where do you want to be
because there's it sounds like there's
opportunities many places I really is
not in some ways they still tend to cast
the principal's out of New York and Los
Angeles you know most of the in the
secondary markets mostly if your local
it's mostly day players or small parts
it's rare that you go up for a lead but
still if you want to get experience and
then go out to LA in New York it's a
good strategy yeah I'm thinking of like
winters bone
it seemed like a lot of people except
for Jennifer Lawrence and a few other
characters dale dickey they were all
based from where was Missouri year yeah
sorry yeah what was was Jennifer
Lawrence living in la at that time or
was she more like I give wasn't she like
blue collar comedy or like one odor that
was it the bill Engvall show or like it
was some kind of show like that I think
she started on before and she had a
small part before winters bone fry I
think she where is she living uh yeah
I'm not sure I should know this wow this
is terrible well that's okay well look
it up afterward but yeah that's okay I
think I think she's rich she's okay now
yeah she's good but but I'm just
thinking of a movie like that or there's
there's other films where you can feel
the authenticity of the place you can
yeah that people like movies like that
are like beasts of the southern wild and
all those none of those people were
actors too and they were great you know
because they weren't trying to be
anything they were just them and yeah
that's a movie like that well you can
see it in the extras even to you just
you just see that maybe they're not as
concerned with being seen and this is no
offense to like la extras but definitely
if anybody's been done extra work on a
set you know people definitely want they
want to do that cross in front of the
camera and it's it's a huge thing for
them but a lot of times those regional
film shoots you can definitely feel just
more real people that are less concerned
with screen time it seems like and
that's why a lot of I think directors
particularly foreign ones like to use
non-actors like there's a great the
Gospel according to st. Matthew pier
paolo pasolini which is my favorite he
made that it's my favorite biblical film
which is interesting considering was
made by a gay communist atheist but he
filmed it in the south of Italy and
everyone in that movie was just people
from the country I think there were a
couple cameos my famous Italian artists
like Jesus was a Spanish economic
student and the he castings he wanted
that authenticity and it feels so
authentic like they just feel and it was
shot in black and white hand held that
just feels like they're kind of local
people who just live out in the
wild were just being with Jesus so it
just feels very authentic well your dad
is also a director do you feel that one
day you'll also want to direct yeah I
think I could I mean I'd really really
really really want to study it cuz
there's just so much you gotta do
there's so many elements you got to
think of I mean it's like sculpture you
know we got to think about sound and the
framing and then there's you know
production time and then just the way
you direct the actors that they're so so
many elements and you have to be good at
everything it's like an MMA fight you
got to be good at boxing and jiu jitsu
and kickboxing and dirty boxing and and
wrestling you just got to be good at all
those areas so as a director you really
going to know your and I'd like to
someday you would okay and lastly um
even though you're in New York and you
do audition do you ever do taped
audition tape yeah and how is that for
you would is there someone reading with
you do you have a brand I always get
someone to read to me it can be hard you
know it's a weird feeling when like
you're not because with normal auditions
like you have a place to go like you
know there's going to be people in the
room and it's going to happen on this
day and this time so it's everything's
very definite with a self taped you know
you don't have any professional people
there with you you got to do it on your
own time and sort of that all yourself
so it is a lot of pressure on yourself
and it can be hard to make it not feel
too casual and but you got to learn how
to do it so in some sense is it almost
easier if you don't have any other
distractions because then you can really
be present like if your reader is
someone that you're comfortable with do
you think you could almost do sometimes
a better job I don't know I kind of I'll
i prefer having a definite time in place
and like being able to prepare myself
before i go in i actually feel sellotape
this more distractions because i feel
like i know exactly what's going to be
in this room when i go into an audition
for everyone's different of course for
me with a self taped eye and say if i do
it at my house it's like I got to make
sure my roommates for quiet or if I'm
doing someone else's place like it's
like we got
make sure that there's what if people
are working around outside or something
and it's like oh I'll put it off till
tomorrow because I gotta do these emails
so I feel like I have more distractions
that I would have a set time in a set
date interesting so it's better to have
to have a time place and a structure to
it for me okay
you